[موسيقى]
اهلا ومرحبا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
احد القوى العسكريه الرئيسيه في افريقيا
ميزانيتها الدفاعيه للعام المقبل 2023
باكثر من الضعف مقارنه بالعام الجاري لتصل
الى اكثر من 22 مليار دولار بحسب مشروع
قانون الماليه الذي اقره مجلس النواب في
انتظار ربط الاتصال
من الجزائر العاصمه الدكتور رضوان بوهيد
الاستاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه الجزائر لدينا اشكال
تقنيه في همم ربط الاتصال
معه سنحاول ذلك هذا الامر الفرصه ترحيب
بضيفي فيها الاستاذ سمير يحيى السياسي
والحقوق اهلا بك ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك على
تربيه هذه الدعوه اهلا بك همم معركه ساخنه
بين النواب وسبب قانون الماليه في الجزائر
هكذا عنه صحيفه الخبر الجزائريه وجهها هذا
اليوم وقبل الخوض في ميزانيه الدفاع بشكل
خاص نتحدث بشكل عام عن وزنه الجزائر
العامه للعام المقبل وبعض الانتقادات
الموجهه لرفع ما وصفت بنفقات التيسير او
التشغيل ميزانيه همم تصل الى نحو 100
مليار دولار السيد سمير تعليقك على
هذه الميزانيه
الميزانيه بشكل عام يعني همم لو كان يعني
الرفع هذا همم
وكنت تقسيم بتاع الميزانيه همم يعني تقسيم
عادل في مجالات عديده ممكن نقول مليح يكون
رفعت ميزانيه ولكن لما يكون التقسيم همم
يعني همم يخلي الانسان يتسائل علاج همم
الدفاع ياخذ قريب 23 مليار دولار
والداخليه قريب ثمانيه ملايين دولار يعني
يبين الداخليه والدفاع يعني بين الوزارتين
عندنا اكثر ما يزيد عن 30% من الميزانيه
و70% على كل المجالات الاخرى التي يعني
بالك تفوق 20 مجال همم التساؤلؤه هنا ما
هوش يعني
لو كانت الميزانيه يعني همم تكون مقسمه
بطريقه يعني همم محكمه وتروح يعني الى
مجالات
للجزائريين محتاجين ان الميزانيه ترفع في
هذه المجالات لكن نقول له فيه يعني في
مرحله ثانيه نتكلموا على المجالات اللي
الجزائريين محتاج انهم تكون عندهم ميزانيه
اكثر بكثير من ميزانيه وزاره الدفاع او
وزاره الداخليه يعني هذا كانه يعني رساله
واضحه كان يعني كل الميزانيه هذه موجهه
الى الامن يعني كاننا همم
واثق انه همم النظام راه يعني متمركس كان
نظام عسكري ونظام نظام امني لان لهذا يعطي
اكبر ميزانيه لهذا همم يعني همم لهذا
المجالين يعني مع ان وزير الماليه يقول ان
التدابير التي جاء بها مشروع قانون
الماليه لسنه 2003
ستعطي دين ملكيه جديده للاقتصاد الوطني
وتعزيز جهود الدوله في مجال السياسه
الاجتماعيه للاسف
لنمكن من ربط الاتصال عبر همم الصوره مع
ضيفنا من الجزائر العاصمه ولكن ما هو معنى
عبر الهاتف ونعتذر منك ونرحب بك من
الجزائر العاصمه الدكتور رضوان الاستاذ
علوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه في جماعه
الجزائر مرحبا بك دكتور ولاء اسف على هذا
التقنيه الذي حاله ان اراك على الشاشه
همم مساء الخير وانا اعتذر بدوري لانه
المشكله تقني في سكايب الخاص بي في اخر
لحظه مع الاسف لاننا قمنا بكل الترتيبات
اللازمه قبل الحلقه لتامين ذلك ولكن للاسف
على كل كل الترحيب بك وسعيد باستضافتك حتى
عبر الهاتف الدكتور رضوان مهيد التعليقك
انت على هذه الميزانيه بشكل عام
وتعليقك على الميزانيه بشكل خاص همم
الميزانيه الدفاعيه يعني هذه الميزانيه
العامه تتضمن زياده غير مسبوق على الانفاق
العسكري في الجزائر لماذا وهل تم فعلا ما
يبرر ذلك استغرب هذا الامر منذ لحظات هنا
في الاستديو الدكتور رضوان مرحبا من جديد
مرحبا بكم بضيفك الكريم طبعا كل مشاهدي
فرنسا طبعا نقاش سيدي الكريم لما نفتح
نقاش حول ميزانيه الدفاع تحديدا بالنسبه
لايكون هناك مشكله اقتصادي مشكل مالي او
ازمه خانقه تحول دون يعني
مضاعفه الرقم او الزياده في في هذا الرقم
لكن الامر لا اعتقد انه يخص الجزائر في
هذا الظرف بالذات وفي ظل التحولات الكبيره
التي يعرفها الجيش الوطني الشعبي من
تطورات الى اخره في ظل التهديدات
المختلفه التماثوليه ولا تماثوليه همم
الموجوده اليوم بالاضافه الى ارتفاع
الاسعار في احداثها في في سوق في سوق
الجيوش صحه همم تعبير
يمكن نفس الاحتياجات
للمطلوبه عام 2018 او 2017 كانت ب 10
مليار دولار ربما هي نفس الاحتياجات اليوم
ب 20 مليار دولار يعني هذا لا يعني انه
هذا الميزانيه مرشحه مثل ما يحاول بعد
الترويج والتهويل للتسلح وسباق التسلح الى
اخره لا هذا يدخل في اطار اعتقد عادي جدا
ويعطي صوره جيده لاحد اعتقد اهم الجيوش في
افريقيا وفي العالم اليوم حسب الترتيبات
المقدمه من طرف المجلات المتخصصه في هذا
المجال اذا تهديده ثمانيه
الحديثه خاصه السيبرانيه ايضا التي تستدعي
ربما تعبئه تكوين تجهيز الى غير ذلك حمايه
المناطق الحدوديه الشاسيه على الجزائر همم
من التنظيمات الارهابيه من مجموعات
الجريمه المنظمه همم لتجاره البشر تهريب
الاسلحه والمخدرات يعني التهديدات كثيره
للغايه على ضوء ايضا التوتر همم الدولي
والحرب الروسيه ايضا على اوكرانيا الى غير
ذلك وضيف ايضا لان ال- ال- التضخم العالمي
هو الذي تسبب في رفع التكلفه تكلفه
التجهيز العسكري هذا ما ارتفاع هذه
الميزانيه بهذا همم الشكل
بكم ارتفعت الميزانيه اكثر من النظافه ب
127%
وتضخم المادي العالمي ارتفع بين ثلاثه
وخمسه بالمئه نحك ولم127 هذا اول تصحيح
يعني للمعلومه الخاطئه ثاني معلومه نعطيها
هذه الميزانيه تمثل نصف ميزانيه الدفاع في
فرنسا فرنسا قوه نوويه وثلث همم الدفاع في
بريطانيا العظمى وروسيا اللذان هم كذلك
قوتين نووييتين
وستفوق هذه الميزانيه ميزانيه تركيا
في حلف الناطور وستلتحق الجزائر بهذه
الميزانيه الى المرتبه 13 او 15 عالميا من
حيث الميزانيه وليس من حيث الحداثه ومن
حيث القوه ومن حيث التكنولوجيا لكن السؤال
الذي اطرحه هل الجزائر ستلتحق الى المرتبه
13 او المرتبه 15 في مجال الصحه في مجال
التعليم في مجال الزراعه في مجال الثقافه
في مجال همم التكوين المهني شاهدنا كلنا
ان الصيف الفائت هذا مات الجزائريون حرقا
لان العتاد الذي همم عنده الحمايه المدنيه
اعتاد تقديم وما عندناش حتى طائره الاخماد
النيران ما قريب 50 جزائري ومئه جزائري
الصيف اللي فات
سيتم ذلك من خلال هذه الميزانيه بانها
نتحدث عن الميزانيه شاميه المدنيه
الجيش الجيش
والامن ووزاره الداخليه الجزائريه
[موسيقى]
تبعث الادويه وتبعث الاكسجين للجزائر هذه
الميزانيه الجيش الميزانيه تاع الامن تمثل
تقاريبا 11 الى 12 قطاع في الجزائر يعني
هل
هذه الميزانيه تفوت كل المشاكل اللي راهم
يعيشوا فيها الجزائريين يوميا طيب لا شيء
يبرر
العسكريه
هي للصحه والتعليم
الثقافه وغيرها من القطاعات الحيويه التي
تهم المواطن الجزائري بشكل مباشر دكتور
رضوان بوهيدل هل تتفق معه
لا هو هو يبدو انه يضيفك مركز على يعني ما
احترامي ليه يعني وشاركت معاه سبق في
برنامج حول تعديل الدستور وتقريبا اني
نسمع نفس الخطاب خليني اقول حرفيا لكن
خليني اقول انه ال ال اليوم الجزائر
رهيب على غيران عدد من دول لما يتحدث عنه
حرائق حتى في فرنسا مواطنون
في فرنسا
لديكم قتلت اكثر من ما قاله قتلت في
الجزائر لمن تحدث عن الجانب الصحيح هذا لا
يعني انه لا ليست هناك لكن لا يجب في
اعتقاد التركيز على ميزانيه دفاع التي
تضعفت لانه تم ايضا مضاعفه عدد من
الميزانيات قطعه اخرى يجب ايضا الرؤيه
فيها الميزانيات الاخرى ايضا كانت فيه
زيادات ولم تبقى مثل السنه الماضيه او ال-
ال-
ارتفعت الميزانيه بشكل بشكل عام
بالشكل هذا لا اعتقد انه هناك دليل انه
هناك بحبوحه وارياحيه ماليه على الاقل في
هذه المرحله لو اعتقد تاني ميزانيه لوزاره
الماليه لانه هناك مشروع لرفع الاجور هناك
مشاريع اخرى لاستيراد السيارات الى اخره
اعتقد انه الجزائر داخل على عده مشاريع
استدعت هذه الرفع في الميزانيه واعتقد انه
ميزانيه الدفاع مبرره على كل المستويات
المستوى
صوره سيميولوجيه والرساله الى العالم انه
لدينا جيش قوي يحتاج الى ميزانيه همم
كبيره للدفاع الجزائر لانه دور ربما ضيفك
همم عنده وقت كثير ما ما صارش الجزائر
الجيش يقوم بادوار متعدده همم
بس هو يقول لك
حاضر ضيفك والله نفس نفس الخطاب
الحصه الماضيه طيب طيب
حتى نتحدث عن هذه الميزانيه وظيفه حين
يقول فقد سميره حياوي ان كل القطاعات
ارتفعت ميزانياتها تقريبا في الجزائر ولا
ان بقي فعلا قطاع التعليم وفق المعلومات
الوارده لدينا حل اا رابعا بحواله همم
ثمانيه فاصل ثلاثه مليارات همم مليار
دولار تقريبا ولكن المقتضيات الحاليه
تستدعي ان تقوم الجزائر يقول لك ضيفي
ويؤكد على ذلك لرفع ميزانيه همم لان
التهديدات والمخاطر الكبرى والظرفيه حساسه
للغايه بالنسبه للجزاء ضيف الى ذلك حتى
ذهب اليه وزير الماليه نفسه وزراء اخرون
من ان ميزانيه 2003 تتضمن مشاريع كثيره
همم زياده همم نفقات التشغيل زياده
الاستثمار المشاريع الاجتماعيه التي تحدث
والدعم المشاريع الدعم الاجتماعي التي
تحدث عنها حتى ضيفي اذا الامر لا يقتصر
فقط على همم الميزانيه الدفاع اضف الى ذلك
ايضا ان هذا يعطي اشارات ايجابيه همم
للخارج عن الدور الجديد الذي تقوم به
الجزائر على المستوى الدولي والمستوى
الاقليمي همم ايضا يجب ان يكون هناك جيش
وقدرات تتوافق مع الدور الذي ترغب الجزائر
في همم
لا يطلب منها ان تضخم ميزانيتها 127 قلت
ان الميزانيه تضخمت في كل المجالات دي
بتعطوني مجال واحد وخيمه 127 بالمئه لا
يوجد هذا وانا راني متوافق مع ضيفك في
حاجه واحده نعم عندي نفس الخطاب وهو خطاب
تصحيح المعلومات الخاطئه التي اسمعها من
طيفك الكريم اولا يقول في بحبوحه ماليه
العجز المالي في 2022
يصل متوسط لاجل المالي الى قدره العجز
المالي في الجزائر الى 5,720 مليار دينار
هذه البحبوحه الاولى انتعاش هي انت عائشه
بفضل ارتفاع اسعار
العالم
ثم همم نقولوا همم الميزانيه هذه اولويه
انا شفت الاولويات بتاع الجزائريين
روح الجزائر
معاناه الجزائريين يوميا وعائلتي في
الجزائر واعرف كل يوم كيف شيعان الجزائر
في قدرته الشرائيه هلا اديك اللي قلت
الاولويه لماذا الاولويه الى التكوين
المهني اذا التع اذا الصحه اذا الثقافه
اذا السياحه الى الزراعه الى انتعاش
الاقتصاد الذي بنيه التحتيه بالطبع
للانتعاش الاقتصادي الذي لا تملكه الجزائر
تصدر الغاز والبترول ولا تصدر اي شيء اخر
من غير من تقريبا من التمور في بعض
الاحيان هذه نقطه هامه
التي تدرسها الاكاديميات
في الدول العريقه والقويه والانسجام بين
الحاكم والمحكوم ولا يوجد اي انسجاه بين
الحاكم والمحكوم لما يعاني المواطن
الجزائري يوميا في حياته وفي شغله وفي
قدرته شرائه هذه القوله الاولويه
المجتمع تعب وتلقى الشعب بتاعك واقف معك
طيب
ونواب حتى في البرلمان الجزائري
فرصه ضيف يرفض ان يتحدث عن بحبوحه ولكن
يتحدث حتى عن انت عاش ماليه تعيشها
الحزينه العامه بفعل ارتفاع عائدات
المحروقات هم يخشون ان يتم تضيع هذه
الفرصه من دون تخطيط جدا لتحقيق التنميه
لانعاش الاقتصاد للخروج من تبعيه
المحروقات لتنويع موارد البلاد من خلال
دعم قوي للتشغيل والاستثمار والم اين
الجزائر من من ذلك خاصه في مساله تطوير
وارداتها حتى لا تبقى رهينه اسعار الطاقه
التي قد
تتغير همم دكتور رضوان بوهيدري
سيد بوهيدل هل انت معي يبدون فقدنا
الاتصال همم
سيد مهيد على كل
اثر عليك السؤال همم يحيى
ربما جلسه متفقا بان الجزائر في بحبوحه
الان من العيش كما قال غيث ولكن هذه
الميزانيه كثيرون يقولون انها ميزانيه
واقعيه لماذا لانها قدرت على اساس سعر
برميل النفط ب 60 دولار
للبرميل الواحد وهمم الاسعار في على
المستوى الدولي بعد اعتباره انه سعر حظر
للغايه الارقام الوارده همم تظهر ان
الاسعار الدوليه هي ما بين 70 يمكن تصل
حتى الى 110 بمعنى ان الجزائر الان في
مرحله يمكن بامكانها تصحيح المسار ليس فقط
على مستوى الميزانيه الدفاع ولكن على
المستويات الاخرى التي كنت تحدثت عنها من
خلال دعم المواطن الجزائري في مقدراته
الشرائيه دعم القطاعات الحساسه
والحيويه ولكن الاولويه هي للامن همم اولا
وقبل كل شيء وكاني بك
لا
تعتبر ان التحديات والرهانات الكبيره
المتعلقه بالامن اييه سعدنا ضيفي
اعود اليك دكتور مهدي لست ادري ما
اتفقدناك تحديدا ولكن
كنت استمعت الى سؤالي والله
نهايه البرنامج
المحروقات دون تخطيط جدا لتحقيق التنميه
من خلال تنويع والدادات البلد حتى لا يبقى
رهين المحروقات همم دكتور رضوان هذه
النقطه التعليقات عليها تحديدا هل انت قلق
ايضا من هذا بهذا الشان ام لا
اكيد هذا شيء مقلق حتى للحكومه حتى للرئيس
احتلني كل الحكومات المتعاقبه كيف يمكن
خروج من التبعيه للمحروقات لكن هل هناك ما
يجبرونا على الخروج من هذه التبعيه ما دام
هناك همم مداخيل وايرادات كبيره في هذا
الدرفه بالذات يجب استغلاله همم دبلوماسيا
ايضا وانت تدري بع زياره المانيا بعد
زياره عبد المجيد تبون الى ايطاليا بعد
خلينا نسميها بين مزدوجتين
الجزائريه لاسبانيا
وتنويع السواق الجزائريه اعتقد انه
الجزائر اليوم لديها ورقه ورقه ورقه الضغط
خلينا نسميها كثير
رومانسيه على اوروبا يمكن المرور الى
مرحله اخرى هذا ال- ال- ال- ال- الاقتصاد
الجزائري من خلال ساعه وان طبعا لا يمكن
لاي دوله لوحدها ان تنوع اقتصادها لكن لكن
يبقى
للاعتراض بانه تبعي همم تبقى مشكل وعائقا
لكن ليس للتنميه ولكن مشكل لك تنويع
الاقتصادي فقط وما هي الا مرحله يقول لك
ضيفي ستشمل القطاعات اخرى وستجمل تنميه
الاقتصاد في اقل من 30 ثانيه لان كنت قد
اعطيتك الكلمه في بدايه الحلقه سيد سمير
يحيى واخت معك باختصار اقل من 20 ثانيه في
كل مره
تكون يعني بتقول مالي يعطى اكبر ميزانيه
للجيش والامن منذ 60 سنه وهو الاقتصاد
الجزائري والمواصل الاولويه
لحاجات اخرى باستنتاج الاقتصاد وانتاج
مستوى الجزائريين ومنذ 60 سنه واحنا في
نفس السياسه يعني انديروا نفس السياسه
ونحب نكون عندنا نتائج اخرى هتكون عندنا
نفس النتائج يعني هيبقى المواطن الجزائري
في يعني ثانوي
النظام في الجزائر ويبقى النظام يعني املي
ويعطي كل الاولويه للامن وليس للانتعاش
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي في الجزائر
همم في ذلك الوقت
همم
الجزائر خاصه في هذه الظرفيه التي تمكينها
من ذلك مع ارتفاع اسعار
برميل النفطي المرحله الحاليه على كل
الشكر الجزيره همم لكوا اعتذر منك مجددا
الدكتور رضوان بهذا الاستاذ علوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه في جماعه الجزائر على
حاله دون توصلك معنا عبر الصوره من
الجزائر العاصمه شكرا جزيلا لك على تربيه
الدعوه شكرا ايضا
السياسي والحقوق على تربيه الكرام